COMMISSIONER BY CALLED ORDER.
PLEASE ADVISE ON AUDIO AND
VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE OF
TODAY FOR SEATING IS ALSO BEING
TELEVISED. OF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. HERE.
LARA GRAYSON THERE THERE
MAIENSCHEIN THERE NOT THAT'S OR
SOME OF THE OTHER PROBLEMS
THERE. WHERE LET ME SEE HERE WE
A QUORUM WE HAVE A CAN AGENDA.
I REQUEST. THREE MOVE THE ROOF
RE REFER ALL OF A THE SENATE
BILL SEVEN ONE CAN SEE I'M
ALSO CAN THAT THIS BILL MAIN BE
TO THE COMMITTEE HAVING A STATE
FISCAL IMPACT INFRASTRUCTURE I
ALSO REQUEST TO REMOVE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. THE JOINT RULE
WAIVER REQUEST FROM CONSENT I
ASK THAT WE VOTE ON BOTH OF
THESE ITEMS SEPARATELY FOR A
GOOD ITEM TWO AND ITEM FIVE ARE
REMOVED FROM THE CONSENT AGENDA
FOR SEPARATE VOTE. ON A IS OUR
MOST ON THE MAIN ROAD THE
CONSENT AGENDA. SOBRE BY MISTER
RIVER SECONDED BY MS COM
LONGER- ALL MATTER SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY HI
COOLEY AYE CARILLO CARILLO HI
FLORA GRAYSON. GRAYSON I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS AYE
MATHIS AYE KIRK SILVA. RICK
SILVA AYE ROMA. RAMOS I. RIVAS
I LEVINE LEVINE ID. DEEP I
MOTION PASSES BURGER IS OUR
MOTION REMAINING TWO WHITE ITEM
TO AND FALL. MOVE A MEASURE
RIVERSIDE AROUND IS CALM WATER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OF A
MASSIVE SEARCH REVIEWS CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY MET CHAIR POINT ON.
OKAY YES. YES MY FOR TO SERVE
ROLE CALLS ON THE. SO WE VOTE
ON ONE AND THEN VOTE ON THE
OTHER. INDIVIDUALLY HARM. WELL
THE MOVE. WELL WE PULLED THEM
OFF TOGETHER. I GUESS I FEEL
EMOTIONAL FORCES FOR THESE TWO
ITEMS. TO GATHER- AND WE'RE IN
THE MIDDLE OF A ROLL CALL. ARE
YOU SEE MR GRAYSON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION THE VOTE WE'RE
ABOUT TO TAKE ON ITEM TWO IN
FIVE THE SPECIAL ON ITEM FIVE
SB SEVEN THIRTY ONE IS JUST A
PROCEDURAL VOTE TO ASSIGN THE
BILL TO A COMMITTEE TO BE HEARD
IN ITS CONTENT AND MERIT AND WE
CAN RESERVEDEBATE ON THE BILL
ITSELF FOR A FLOOR ITEM AND
TODAY IS AGAIN JUST SIMPLY A
PROCEDURAL VOTE TO ASSIGN THE
BILL TO COMMITTEE. THAT IS
CORRECT. THANK YOU. MANSER
TROOPERS CALL THE ROLL. COOLEY
HI COOLEY AYE CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
ACCOUNT MARKER KAMLAGER I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS NO MATHIS NO PORK SILVA.
BURKE SILVA I RAMOS. RAMOS NOT
VOTING RIVAS RIVAS I LEVINE
LEVINE I DEEP. DEEP NOT VOTING
THE MOTION PASSAGE PROMOTIONS
PASS AND THIS RULES COMMITTEE
IS ADJOURNED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.